احنا سالنا الناس في مصر من هو اعظم لاعب
كره قدم في التاريخ نسمع راي الشارع ونرجع
لك
[موسيقى]
ليونيل ميسي عشان هو تقريبا عمل كل حاجه
في الكوره
عمل كل حاجه
اكثر من اي لاعب يعني كان اي مدافع بيدخل
عليه بيبقى خايف هو كده كده هيعدي
كل حاجه
ليو ميسي نجم الارجنتين طبعا محقق خمس
بطولات كاس عالم اوروبا دوري همم
ليو ميسي طبعا بالارقام والحساب والمهارات
طبعا هيجيء الاسطوره اللي مش هيتكرر يعني
رحمه الله مارادونا ده حاجه طبعا لما
نحسبها مهارات ما حدش جاء زيه على مستوى
تاريخ العالم كله بالنسبه مارادونا يعني
لاعب ما فيش لاعب بيعرف يعمل اللي بيعمله
مارادونا
مارادونا لاعب كبير
بيعرف يتحرك بالكوره ازاي بيمر بالكوره
ازاي بيعرف يسجل ازاي الراجل بيخترق اي
دفاع ازاي
متكامل برده بيجيب اهداف اهداف
تحس ان هو بيعمل حاجه مختلفه حاجه انت مش
متخيل ان هو يلعبها ازاي
فهي فعلا ان ممكن اي لاعب مثلا يتعوض ثاني
يعني عندك مثلا رونالدو ممكن يتعوض مثلا
طبعا همم
اسطوره اسطوره الله يرحمه يعني يعني طبعا
من الناس اللي هم سطروا التاريخ في كره
القدم انما نيجي دلوقتي الحالي او العصر
الحالي طبعا همم بالنسبه لي يعني رقم واحد
وعشره محمد صلاح
يعني ده اعظم لاعب في العالم دلوقتي
[موسيقى]